you sit in the blind is engaged the
override hi I'm Nicole stop nicole stott
is a retired astronaut and here's me in
space today I'm going to look at how
astronauts are portrayed in Hollywood
cracking helmet Total Recall
it's trying to present this exaggerated
dramatis sized kind of view of a helmet
opening up in space thank you
the helmet itself is really very durable
there's you know there's parts on it
that if you hit it hard enough you could
crack them if you I mean really moved
fast towards a you know like a sharp
piece of metal or something we try our
best to avoid any contact with anything
with the helmets because they'll they
can scratch easily too when we do
spacewalks we're always talking about
doing a glove check or a crew you know
crew member check where you look each
other over and make sure you don't see
anything that looks like it might be a
problem and we each you know about after
every hour we look over our whole gloves
to make sure we haven't got any tears or
holes in them where all of your air goes
you know spewing out to the deadly
vacuum of space but overall the suits
and the helmets are really very durable
and have done a great job protecting us
in space spacewalk and gravity I
remember the first time seeing this
scenes in gravity and just being so
impressed by the visuals can't beat the
view I mean just the movement and the
sound of it was was so reminiscent of
what I felt when I was outside and what
I saw is doing up there appears to be
doing some form of the Macarena there's
definitely not as much chatter as what
you are hearing we try very hard to keep
it to you know what the tasks are about
yes an area we might be playing music
inside of the shuttle but that's not
something you'll hear throughout all of
the you know the comm that's going on
the spacewalks themselves are all really
choreographed down to probably five
minute increments and maybe smaller
depending on the task Houston will be
letting us know how close we are on the
time line and then we always have
somebody inside the space ship to
letting you know where to go next and
what to do
I go to assist dr. stone and removing
the panel assistance appreciated the
thing that stands out to most to me is
that you'd never have George Clooney or
any other crew member just kind of
jetpacking around while the the
spacewalk was going on a lot might still
prefer my 67 Corvette the suits that we
wear though do have jetpacks integrated
into them but they're not that big unit
that he was wearing never crossed my
mind and they are meant to only be used
in case of emergency if for some reason
you do get separated from the shuttle or
the space station and you're tumbling
and you need to get back back to the
shuttle
that's that's when you would use those
you never want to have to use this not
one second now shut it down yeah that
was frustrating to me when I watched
that movie and she didn't just stop like
put the tools down and just you know
abort
when they call for that abort you saw
how Clooney's character immediately boom
boom boom back to the station
disconnecting talking to the ground
about where all the crew members are how
they're getting back in
[Music]
we absolutely train for these what you
would think of as worst-case scenarios
where you have to abort immediately any
number of things could go wrong out
there that would require you to
immediately have to go back to your safe
place inside of the station or the
shuttle this situation where out of you
know almost out of nowhere comes this
massive field of debris from the missile
strike has caused a chain reaction is
really unlikely there are people on the
ground that track you know single pieces
of debris in space that are like the
size of your hand or even smaller and
somebody down on the ground would have
seen that coming away before the call
that they they were given in this movie
we have to go go go
spinning off like that I think it's
probably one of the greatest fears of
any space Walker he's did you copy this
hasn't happened to anybody in real life
on the shuttle or on the station but we
do train for that as one of you know our
emergency scenarios and we do that in
the virtual reality simulator ludicrous
speed in space balls
[Music]
I have seen that in a lot of films the
stars that you see all of a sudden it
becomes these lines and I think it's
just to give you the feeling of going
really super fast I would say that the
you know the speed of the Space Shuttle
is you know in the grand scheme of
things a little bit ludicrous I mean
it's 17,500 miles an hour which is about
five miles a second you don't get the
lights like streaming by you like that
but you know you're going fast and you
know of course we're orbiting the the
earth for about 250 miles up we don't
really have a like a gas pedal for you
know accelerating or Chris increasing
speed I guess you could make an
equivalent we've got like this little
handle that you know can cause the
thrust to increase that look like what
you would fly the robotic arm with we
just push on it and it gives this little
burst of thrust out of the back of the
you know the thrusters
of course launching you know that's kind
of this controlled explosion happening
below you so the crew really doesn't
have a button or a throttle or a handle
for that
robotic arm on the ISS in life I used to
play catcher but only in t-ball
[Music]
on the space station and then even on
the the space shuttle before we had this
robotic arm big white you know long
cream looking kind of thing and we could
move equipment around with it we could
move whole big modules around with it we
could even strap people to the end of it
and move them around with it during a
spacewalk in things what's different in
this films and it's all agree we made a
fuss and nos mistake I mean there's a
number of things but in this scene
though - you know that spacecraft is
moving really fast the arm itself while
it could I think physically be
controlled to grab the the spacecraft
moving in I think the way it was moving
in the speed and the difference between
what was going on with the station it
probably would have just ripped the arm
right off of the the space station yeah
we do grab vehicles like this that are
flying to the space station with cargo
in them and I had the chance to do that
one time with the Japanese cargo vehicle
it was the first one that flew up and
then we had to grab it with the arm and
because most the time they dock
automatically to the station so that was
really fun I mean we that was the first
time we used the arm and flew it in a
totally different way probably as close
to this as you could get but the vehicle
flew up and just kind of hovered next to
us I did like the way they moved through
the station
they show um floating and flying several
times and that that felt very real to me
that little metal rectangular thing
that's a drink bag kind of like a big
pre Sun bag or something that happens
sometimes when you let go of something
and don't they'll grow it down and the
view through the window is really good I
you know I don't know I in these movies
I don't know how they do it make it look
so real really look good astronaut
training in first man con you might
encounter in space challenge is to
stabilize the Machine before you pass
out first victim Armstrong like that
first victim so in this scene you see
Neil Armstrong in what was called the
multi-axis trainer and this was used to
train astronauts to get into all kinds
of like disorienting configurations that
might happen because you know in space
there is no up or down and if you start
you know these different rotations you
might have to fly yourself out of it
and you can see that he's he's having to
complete a task while going through this
really dynamic simulation if you work
the math it follows that is absolutely
what we would have to do as part of any
astronaut training that is absolutely
what you will feel like when you are
going through something like this I will
say though I'm thankful that these days
we don't use the multi-axis trainer
anymore we have different kinds of
simulators like through virtual reality
we can get thrown off the space station
like during a spacewalk and spun around
and then have to use little jet packs to
get ourselves oriented just thinking
about this lecture Neil Armstrong never
actually used this trainer but it was
used for other programs during that
early space flight time and so it does
represent what the astronauts would go
through as part of their training now
training montage from Armageddon the
United States astronauts trained for
years you have 12 days when you train in
the big pool there's divers all around
you safety divers divers that are
helping you with the equipment all of it
getting you in and out of the pool the
underwater work looks just like we would
do if we were training to do a spacewalk
thankfully in space it's easier to move
around in those suits and you just got
to figure out how to get yourself
stopped if you get moving too fast
but the the reality of what's going on
in that pool is just like I remember it
the underwater training for one
spacewalk I think I did seven or eight
six-hour runs in the pool you have 12
days they couldn't do I don't think all
of this training and testing in 12 days
but I don't think they would need to for
this kind of mission either for the
movie I think what they're trying to do
is just give them like familiarization
with what things would feel like
I love that they included the training
in the teeth the t-38 Jets that's the
airplanes we used and that we still use
for astronaut training we do that
because you want to get familiar with
what it's like to work in a really
complex system like a space shuttle
would be the airplanes provide that
you're in a real extreme environment
you're doing very challenging things I
mean they're flipping you're around you
think we'll get hazard pay out of this
it's almost like the multi-axis trainer
where you're having to be a little bit
disoriented and still you know work
safely every movie where they have
people flying in airplanes like this
jets the mask is always off one of the
first things you do when you strapped
into the jet is put the mask on and
start breathing the oxygen and that's
one of the things that keeps you the
safest in that airplane and so never
would we be flying in these jets with
the mask on we need you to train them
down here you want to send these boys
into space fine sure they'll make good
astronauts they don't know jack about
drilling there's kind of a futuristic
possibility in this as we start to fly
more in space we really are going to be
looking at going to the people that have
these trade skills to fly them in space
as astronauts the United States
government just has to save the world
removing helmet in space mission to Mars
yeah if you remove your helmet in space
that's that's a really bad day and I
think in this scene you know they are
trying to give you the like the ultimate
view of what it would look like sadly it
would take a little bit more time in the
vacuum of space all of the fluids in
your body are gonna want to escape and
they're gonna do that in a way that's
like they're boiling off of you which is
which is not probably a good feeling and
then you will ultimately freeze like
this but you'll suffocate before that
ever happens docking a spacecraft
interstellar
[Music]
it's necessary I love the way they they
did this scene it's really an extreme
example of you know of a docking
scenario and an emergency situation like
this this is no time for caution faced
by black out you take the stick we do a
lot of training where they're trying to
put you in that extreme situation and to
understand the capabilities of your own
spacecraft and how you could manually
fly and I just love that they spoke
through it you ready and then visually
they showed you how those two spaceships
almost look like they weren't moving at
all when they finally came together when
in fact they were still really just like
spinning like crazy
come on baby
so we use a lot of different thrusters
on our spacecraft to move you know - you
know thrust and move higher up into
orbit or I think in this scene they use
a term retro thrusters the retro
thrusters which is one that would
actually thrust in a direction that
would cause you to slow down and kind of
back in to orbit again or to drop down
in orbit to go from high to low and
again I like that they use that
appropriately in this film
I just really think they did a good job
on this you know and and portraying the
like the physical load that you would be
feeling on your body while that's
happening so when I talk about load like
you know feeling the load you know when
you accelerate us like this this feeling
of weight on you and so you're loaded up
with with G's and on the shuttle when we
launched it was like 3 G's is what you
would feel so it feels like 3 of you're
sitting on top of you in this
interstellar scene where there starts
spinning as fast as that space station
was you think about it you know some of
those carnival rides that you're on when
they spin you all of a sudden you feel
like you're pinned back cuz there's this
increased load on your body
you know you see the one character is
just really leaned over in her seat and
ultimately passes out I think that's
interesting because you've got
McConaughey flying the spacecraft and
I've always noticed this when you're the
one flying you physically can overcome
more than if you're the passenger you're
the person that's kind of just in a
benign position there and that doesn't
mean that ultimately you might not pass
how to if the load gets to be too much
and you're not recovering properly but
somehow you respond to it in a way that
allows you get through more AI on
spaceships and 2001 Space Odyssey all
right hell I'll go in for the emergency
airlock without your space helmet Dave
we're going to find that bother
difficult how I would argue with you
anymore open the doors Dave this
conversation can serve no purpose
anymore goodbye right now I think the
the current status of artificial
intelligence or AI on our space missions
is that we're not really saying we have
AI what we do have is automated control
of things and that's a great thing
because then the crew isn't having to
interact all the time to maintain the
systems or ensure that everything is
good that can happen automatically I
think you know what the problem is just
as well as I do our hope is that the AI
whichever ones we do employ at some
point are not set up that they could
take control of our spaceship I'm sorry
Dave I'm afraid I can't do that
sharing oxygen and a spacesuit Rocket
Man could we stay on this heading for
another 20 minutes
I see the pillow
[Music]
what I didn't do anything oh my god
yeah not so accurate here they show the
suit blowing up like that I think to
just kind of give you a visual you know
reference to what is going on inside it
there's actually you know pretty good
structure and that's in that suit but
it's just not flexible in a way unless
it was a huge amount of you know of
pressure blasting off inside of the
thing yeah I don't think we could
produce that it would be a really bad
day so we have primary life-support
systems built into the suit that's where
you're getting your normal oxygen from
primary oxygen tank Lee we need to
preserve his SOP solution there's a
secondary tank that's pressurized with
the oxygen that allows you to you know
backfill if if you have a leak or are
running out fast maybe fortunately we
don't have alignment you can air lock
event horizon
[Applause]
[Music]
so similar to mission to Mars this
really is kind of an exaggerated
presentation of how the body would react
to being exposed to the vacuum of space
on the space station right now we have
an airlock module and it's the place
that you go and you get all ready to go
out on your spacewalk and it's a place
that allows you to isolate from the main
spacecraft where you still want to
breathe regular air and you still want
to you know live and survive and
maintain a normal atmospheric pressure
and the airlock gives you the capability
to dump all of that pressure and
equalize with the vacuum of space
commander gets in and he's got him back
inside and they close that outer hatch
and it's like almost immediately they're
opening the inner hatch and going inside
there's a lot of things happening around
it it takes about half an hour for in a
normal re-entry for the airlock to
repressurize there was a case of a guy
who was doing a test like a spacesuit
test and somehow got exposed to the you
know to the vacuum to find out what
happened to the other he reports that he
felt boiling of his spit on his tongue
and in the end he was fine I have no
idea how long that was I mean it had to
be quick because as soon as that started
happening they'd be looking at how do we
get back in there and get this guy out
I'd like some answers doctor you have
the potential of you know popping
eardrums and and and hurting yourself by
that pressure change so you want to
bring that that change on slowly that so
that your body you know can react to it
in a good way
self-destruct button in Star Trek 3
awaiting final code or one-minute
countdown code zero zero zero
[Music]
destruct sequence is really there's
nothing like this on board but the range
safety guys do have this capability an
Air Force team that's on the ground and
they watch their monitoring whenever a
spacecraft is launching they watch to
make sure that it's maintaining control
and so they have the capability of
flipping this switch and terminating the
flight computer destruct sequence one
which would you know take the crew as
well if there was the possibility of it
coming back and you know causing harm to
a greater population destruct sequence
completed any
it would be an explosion yeah so and
they would do that in a way that it you
know was as safe as possible in the air
before you know the vehicle came back
and impacted the land turn death into a
fighting chance to live I think you
learn about it right going into flight
training you're learning about how the
flight is controlled and managed and
that's just you know that's one part of
it what have I done what you had to do
g-force training in Space Cowboys so we
have the opportunity as shuttle crew
members to go experience the centrifuge
so this machine that kind of spins you
around and simulates not just the
g-forces that you'll feel
you experience them like you would as
you were launching so it takes you
through the same trajectory that you
would experience launching on the space
shuttle and they mentioned it in the
film it's it's three G's and you're on
your back and it's coming through your
chest which really is a lot easier to
handle then you know in an airplane
where you're doing aerobatic and pulling
a lot of G's it's coming through your
head and you're having to squish down
like this I'm sure you people think
you're putting on a great show but this
is not a toy getting sucked into space
and aliens
on the space station we had three what
we called three primary emergencies and
it was fire toxic atmosphere like you
know high concentration ammonia getting
into the air and depressurization which
was like a hole in your spaceship and
you didn't even want a little hole
because little holes mean the air is
going out and if you can't find that
hole and isolate it it means that you're
gonna have to you know get in your
spaceship and head home because you know
all the air will be gone and you won't
be able to breathe there anymore
if you get a hole it's gonna rush out
really quickly and so in doing so it'll
pull things towards the hole so if the
hole is big enough it can pull you right
out with it same thing is true in an
airplane when you're flying in a plane
you'll hear about like depressurization
or in movies you've seen like the door
fly open and people get sucked out too
and that happens in space as well
another scene in gravity crying in space
when you say your prayer for me or is it
too late I mean I'd say one for myself
but I've never traded my life
[Music]
yeah you can cry in space you can cry
pretty much anywhere it's a little
different in that you know you're you're
floating you're in in microgravity and
when you squirt out water it comes out
and like little spheres this like equal
loading all around it the tear just kind
of coats your eye or builds up in like a
little pool and you know in the duct of
your eye
there's nothing causing it to get pulled
out of your eyes you know she was moving
around a little bit so it could I mean
if she had been crying enough and the
tears had built up enough and you know
squeezed your eye if if it separates
from your eye or your body it will be
like little you know balls of tears
floating away
conclusion yeah I hope you've enjoyed
this kind of comparison between what
goes on in the movies and what happens
in real life as much as I have I am so
thankful for the science fiction that we
are presented with I think it gives us
an opportunity to think about what our
future could be like already we've seen
so much sci-fi that's turned into SCI
fact that I am really hopeful for what
we'll see in the future and I hope that
we can continue to compare over time
what we're doing in real life and how
we're imagining it in the sci-fi movies
[Applause]